A very useful and concise way of describing
the grey levels within an image is using a
tool called a histogram.
Here I have a contrived and low resolution
image, where the pixel grey values vary between
0, which is black, and 10, which is white.
We can consider the histogramming process
as a sorting process. I am going to take the
first pixel, which has got a grey scale value
of 6, and I am going to drop it into the bin
for pixels with a value of 6. And I am going
to take the next pixel which has got a value
of 10, and I am going to drop it into the
bin for pixels of value of 10, and so on.
And we repeat this process on and on until
we have coloured all of the pixels in the
image.
And we have this histogram. At a glance this
histogram tells us some very interesting things
about the image. If all of the pixels are
at the left-hand side of the histogram, this
tells us that it is a very dark image. Conversely,
if all of the pixels are at the right-hand
side of the histogram, this tells us that
it is a very bright image.
You have very likely encountered histograms.
They are commonly displayed in the viewfinder
of a camera. What we are seeing here is the
viewfinder of an iPhone camera app and we
can see the histogram here on the display.
The left-hand side of the histogram corresponds
to the dark pixels, and the right-hand side
of the histogram corresponds to bright pixels.
If I move the camera from this view to down
underneath my desk where it is all very dark,
we can see that there are an increasing number
of dark pixels in the scene. As I bring the
camera up from underneath the desk and point
it out the window where it is very bright,
we see the distribution of pixels moving more
towards the bright end of the histogram.
If I repeat the process, but this time I have
the camera set to automatic exposure control,
what happens now is that the software within
the camera is trying to keep the histogram
balanced. It is trying to keep an even mixture
of dark pixels and bright pixels, so that
the average is somewhere in the middle. And
the behaviour this time is quite different,
when we look under the desk, we can see the
wires and the carpet.
When we look out the window, we can now quite clearly see the world outside.